Prince Harry can't wait to take on daddy
duty the 34 year old royal blessed us
with another adorable moment during a
stop in Auckland New Zealand on Tuesday
where he reportedly gushed about his
upcoming role journalist Carolyn Durand
tweeted this video of the sweet exchange
riding hashtag Prince Harry told a
well-wisher he was over the moon about
becoming a father with a big grin on his
face
today when she told him it's a lot of
hard work and to cherish every moment he
said oh I know I'm ready the moment
happened during a walkabout at
Auckland's viaduct where Harry and Megan
greeted a slew of excited fans
[Music]
the royal couple was given a very
personal welcome in the form of a
marching band performing greenback
boogie the theme song to Megan's former
show suits
[Music]
cameras also caught this heartwarming
shot of Megan stunning in a nude fitted
brandon maxwell dress and Burberry
trench coat and cradling her tiny but
growing baby bump as we've seen her do
several times throughout the tour but I
also really care about what I do the
royal parents tepee have given us a
number of adorable moments since
announcing Megan's pregnancy at the
start of their 16 day tour Harry first
addressed the news that a reception held
on their first night in the land down
under
we also generally couldn't think of a
better place to announce the upcoming
baby be it a boy or a girl so thank you
very very much
and again during his speech at the
Invictus games opening ceremonies I want
to say something directly to our hosts
the people of Australia first of all
thank you for the welcome you have given
Megan and I over the last few days I
have been so proud to be able to
introduce my wife to you and we have
been so happy to be able to celebrate
the personal joy of our newest addition
with you all
[Applause]
you